on sait les stars sont nombreuses à
soutenir publiquement des associations
ou des causes humanitaires mais si
certaines se servent de leur notoriété
pour mettre en lumière des combats qui
leur tiennent à coeur d'autres ou une
façon beaucoup plus mercantiles de voir
les choses pour redorer leur image ou
carrément faire du business certaines
stars semblent prêtes à tout ces
derniers jours c'est le candidat de
télé-réalité vivian qui a annoncé la
sortie d'un bracelet en association avec
un joaillier dont les bénéfices seront
reversés pour sauver les animaux en
australie victimes des incendies depuis
longtemps la grande mode du charity
business s'est répandue produits dérivés
concert dédié ou participation des stars
à des émissions pour récolter des fonds
pour des associations 6 qui veut gagner
des millions et est devenue coutumière
de ce genre de pratique fort boyard est
aussi un endroit où les stars se
pressent pour combattre leurs peurs et
récolté plusieurs milliers d'euros pour
des associations il ya quelques mois on
se souvient également des dons de
plusieurs grandes fortunes françaises
pour notre dame qui avait interrogé sur
l'effet de communication autour de ces
dons qui pour certains ont été
défiscalisée des stars qui s'affichent
publiquement et revendiquent leur bonne
action alors selon vous le charity
business vraie démarche ou démago le
faire aujourd'hui critiquée parce que
vous faites certainement sortez moi de
là je suis une célébrité à may
association n'oubliez pas les paroles et
associations qui veut gagner des
millions à et associations qui veut chez
pas quoi le fait qu'ils associations
partout on peut plus rien critiquer plus
rien dire
donc effectivement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on s'en sert ou pas il ya une anecdote
assez hallucinante d'ailleurs de race
elle qui les ai dit quelque chose dans
les loges tout à l'heure sur les assos
oui en fait quand on veut participer à
une émission telle que fort boyard
par exemple quand on nous demande une
association il faut que ce soit une
grosse association quand cela c'est pas
toi qui l'a choisi si mais il faut
choisir en priorité des grosses
associations avec des structures et il
en donne une liste non non non du tout
du tout d'accord mais pas choisir une
grosse association papier par exemple
moi j'ai participé à à faire conclut je
voulais je voulais reversés à une petite
association qui lutte contre l'autisme
mais malheureusement ce n'était pas
possible parce qu'il manquait voilà des
justificatifs et c'est ça alors j'ai dû
choisir la cession des bonnes fellation
des miss france d argent d'argent et
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'argent et moi
j'ai pas citer non mes sacs et des
émissions parfois sur d'autres chaînes
ou où effectivement là la personnalité
ou même aller mal à la personnalité dix
minutes avant on lui dit la sauce c'est
ça elle sert à ça et elle fait ça mais
tu as la personnalité qui perd touché
jeu
je m'éclate mais j'ai pas dit que
c'était mal gré c'est qu'encore une fois
il ya du charity-business mais juste un
mot sur le vivant c'est vrai qu'a fait
les anges qui est charmant qu'on a plus
vu du tout cas 600 1000 followers et
pouf il réapparaît sur la cause des
koalas en australie alors là avec avec
un bracelet en grèce et que la fourrure
absolument identique en de lapin mais
j'aimerais que tu m'expliques non en
vrai je pense que déjà vivions vous le
connaissez pas bien c'est quelqu'un qui
est hyper entier qui y perd sincère et
moi j'ai vu je les ai vus travailler sur
son projet ça fait des mois qu'ils
bossent dessus qui m'en parlent tout le
temps qu'ils m'appellent tout le temps
j'étais en vacances j'ai même différence
de minutes de vol est désolant c'est
qu'à chaque fois que quelqu'un sait
quelque chose de joli 2 propre de toute
manière vous allez me refais pas la
culture magali magail
il a pas besoin de ça qu'est-ce qu'il en
a à faire aujourd'hui il a pas besoin de
ça je vous le dis ah bon il est bien
plus à l'abri que beaucoup d'entre nous
ici je connais bien c'est parce qu'il
est à l'abri qu'il a fait les angles 10
milliards d'eur le thriller le bracelet
dina le bracelet il va l'argent c'est
quoi il ya 3 euros qui valent à et le
reste bas où les 20 35 euros il ya 5
euros qui vont à l'association
pensez vous qu'un ca acheté un bouquet
1,17 euro il ya 3 euros pour les choses
qu'en france à la main ces découpes à la
prépa pardon ça me rend chose qui te dit
cet homme avait déjà fait venir sous
l'eau tu vois il met à l'étagé des non
j'aurais dit oui si j'avais su ça 35
euros et afin que rien à foot et 30
euros dans sa porsche pour monter des
artisans mathieu faut qu'il soit payé 30
euros est associé avec problème si
ouverte de l'argent je comprends pas
pourquoi mais le gars va se faire
attaquer parce qu'hier donc ça veut dire
que sur les pub sur le dos sur le dos
des incendies en australie sur un sur un
timbre est à 35 euros à 30 euros dans sa
poche sa communauté le suis il aurait pu
le faire sans il aurait pu ne rien
donner via gmail à bord alors même s'il
sait que vous critiquer pour critiquer
en mayenne
mais il se sert pas de la cause pour
vendre le bracelet c'est le versant
n'est pas nouveau il ya un cas très
connu des années 90 la fin des 90 ou
elton john ressort candle in the wind en
hommage à lady di il dit tout va revenir
des assiettes des associations sauf que
sur le cd single il ya un deuxième titre
non il prend tout lui guillaume écouter
tout ça c'est très bien vous adorez
critiqué les émissions qui font part des
bulls moi je constate juste que en 2018
il ya moins 150 millions qui sont donnés
par les français en moins pour les
associations de kay de paris est bien
moins 5%
pourquoi parce que l'on s'est créés en
france ce sont les vieux qui donne le
plus est la hausse de la csg
et puis après les avantages fiscaux qui
ont été données comment dire aux grandes
fortunes font que en gros quand on donne
c'est parce qu'on peut le défiscaliser
de sécuriser absolutiser absolument
voilà donc en fait on donne beaucoup
moins ouais je trouve très bien que des
émissions de télé ça fait très bien
savait il a moins de dons mais moi je
crie dit il
attention attention fort boyard par
exemple qui veut gagner des millions et
cetera les artistes ne sont pas payés
mais attention je dis bien que moi
j'avais voulu visiter j'aurais même
chose quand quelqu'un mais quelqu'un va
aux [ __ ] et qu'on dit t'as vu le
fait d'aller aux [ __ ] du coup on n'a
rien entendu certaines chansons on les
appellera enregistrait 7 fait gagner de
l'argent peu importe il a fait monter
l'action pour une critique n'a jamais
les assassins et les émissions qui s'en
servent mais vivian pardon comme je suis
un peu énervé
s'il elle à paris la semaine prochaine
je la vide dans l'émission qui viennent
et on en parlera